- So I heard that you also
moved back to Atlanta, right?
- I just moved back to Atlanta.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- I bought a couple
acreage, a couple acres
out in the country part of Atlanta.
- [Kelly] I love that.
- And I have 12 little white neighbors.
And let me tell you, so.
- 12 little white neighbors?
- I have to tell you this story.
So, they Googled me
and I thought they was
gonna say I'm a comedian.
And I called the old owner.
He called me one day.
He's like, Patricia, we know who you are.
And I'm like, uh-oh,
they done seen my dirty comedy on Netflix.
And I was like, okay.
He's like, we Googled you
and we so happy to have
you in the neighborhood,
and we all know that you're
Oprah Winfrey's sister.
- Wait, what?
- We both have the same
name, Patricia Lee.
And they think I'm Oprah's sister.
And I'm trying to tell them,
I'm not Oprah's sister,
my sister smoke crack.
(Kelly laughing)
- Right.
- And I can't convince
these 12 white people
I'm not Oprah's sister. I'm like, no!
I wish I was Oprah's sister!
- [Kelly] Why? Why?
- Go for it! Go with it, yeah.
- I would lean into that.
Yes I am.
- So every time I go to look at my house,
'cause I'm remodeling,
I got cookies and cakes
and items left by side the door.
And I was like.
- And you'd be like, I'll tell her
it's one of my favorite things.
It's like, it's like, I would totally.